there is an island on this map that
doesn't actually exist but it showed up
on this map from 1908 that claims that
some whaling ship discovered it it would
be one thing if this just appeared on
some old map as a mistake but it started
to appear on a bunch of other maps
including Google Maps which showed Sandy
Island up until 2012 when scientists
aboard a ship crossed this area and
found nothing so how did this fake
Island survive on maps for like a
hundred years scientists think that
maybe the whaling ship that discovered
the island actually saw a bunch of rocks
that had been ejected from an underwater
volcano and they were like hey look
there's an island but why did this error
remain for so long basically it was a
long game of telephone since people
rarely travel through this area this
non- island was transferred from one map
to another until it made its way into
this database which took physical
nautical maps and made them digital this
database happened to be one of the most
widely used sources of modern map data
including buy wait for it Google Maps
and they swiftly removed it once they
realized that